it was october 2004 i was eight years
old turning nine in three weeks
and that reno tournament was a very big
occasion because
there was a guest at the tournament and
my dad told me about this guest and i
was like oh my god it's this is spasky
boris spassky
boris spassky world champ x world
champion lost to fisher
boris faski who was at that time 67
years old
still alive still going strong was a
guest at the tournament and he was
giving a simult
a simultaneous exhibition where you play
many people at the same time
and my dad for a preemptive birthday
present had signed me up for the simul
which happened before the tournament
began
i was rated approximately 1600 and my
brother
and i were playing side by side and i
was like you guys have to understand
eight-year-old me spassky is like god
i'm like i better not [ __ ] this up like
i better give him a good fight i know
i'm gonna lose but i better give him a
good fight
and um i come to the board you know good
pen
you know i'm nervous my parents are
standing behind me i'm like i'm not
going to be the first guy to lose i'm
not going to be the first guy to lose
i'm going to be the first guy to lose
so this is the game it's actually a very
instructive game i'm going to fast
forward through it um i didn't even have
a few day rating i played the night or
spassky goes with this line and spassky
i castle
into the attack i castled here horrible
move spassky demolishes me wins a piece
he drives my king out and he checkmates
me on the 20th move this is the end of
the game
queen g6 checkmate i resigned in this
position
realizing that there's no way to stop
checkmate on one look at my king
20 moves first game to end first game
and um when i ended the game of course
my dad was fuming
and he put on a good face but he told me
something that really pissed me off the
time i was like crying
he said you did one thing correctly in
this game
you resigned at the right moment you
were courteous in resigning you didn't
play until checkmate
and uh he was trying to be encouraging
as he always did but um
that ticked me off so much
i got tears turned into tears of anger
and in the actual tournament that
started the next day i got six points
out of six games
i crushed everybody in like 30 moves and
i won my section that was the first
tournament i had
won at an adult level the first adult
tournament i'd won
yeah so that was the story sorry to like
take so long on it but it's just a
formative
experience in my in my career then i
played spassky and assimil once again
several years later
i played spassky in 2006 as a 2000 and i
managed to make a draw and so did my
brother by the way
so it was a crushing victory but that
was the best motivation
[Music]
gigahertz with black okay let's play a
sicilian
let's play sicilian thank you so much
gupps i really appreciate it
very sweet guys very sweet reaffirming
my faith in humanity
i just do what's what's natural for me
now f4
this is a reasonable move but it's not a
great move
the reason it's not a great move is
because
let's talk about first principles
white's not developing a piece
instead white is weakening the king
now again if we reason very basically
what do we do when our opponent rather
than developing we consist king what is
the act that we have to take what is the
action we have to undertake
we have to open the center i'm going to
hammer that in your minds
let's open the center right sometimes
you don't need to make trust harder than
it is
now there's a couple of complicating
specific factors here if he takes on d5
okay he doesn't so e5 whenever a pawn is
pushed
this far we need to understand the
drawbacks of the move what square
does the move e5 grant to one of our
pieces
and we don't need to access this square
immediately it's just real estate that
we sort of now have
but there is a sort of principle where
we want to develop knights before
bishops now the reason we don't want to
put the bishop on f5
is that maybe one day he'll play knight
f3
and if he plays knight f3 you know maybe
i'll want to put the bishop on g4
that might be something i want to do on
second thought i don't want to do that
because he's going to play h3 he's going
to forcibly unpin himself
and so we're going to play bishop f5
we're going to play bishop
bishop g4 would be kind of an empty pin
due to h3
and if bishop h5 i'll show this after
the game
let me turn to a new page i'll show this
after the game but he basically traps
the bishop
one second guys
okay so the move c3
is like steph curry raising his arms up
we know where he's passing the
basketball
he wants to play the move d4 can we stop
that do we have to allow him
to build up this very massive poncho and
we actually don't
we're going to get there first hey we're
going to get there first
we are going to get there first and what
this does
is this dis-attaches this pawn chain
from this pawn chain which makes
everything kind of a little bit weaker
now steph gray's passing is not
predictable but he better step up his
three-point shooting game or i'm gonna
have
a problem okay this is a good move
now we need to understand a couple
things here before we proceed
the first is is this something that we
need to actively deal with is he
actually like
threatening to take our night do we are
we okay with allowing that
so you guys are falling for the
nereditsky trick when i ask a question i
think a lot of people assume the answer
has to be no
but the reason we're actually okay with
allowing him because what i want you
guys to understand
is that if he takes on c6 and we take
back yes it is true that our pawn
structure is not as good
but look very carefully at the squares
that he leaves behind all of the squares
that i'm currently highlighting in blue
we can put a bishop on d3 the bishop to
e4 all of those light squares are going
to be unattended
and if he ever plays the move d3 then
that pawn is going to be very very weak
so we have determined that we can
proceed with our development
what does that mean what move should we
play
uh maybe to open up the e7 square for
our bishop or our knight
yeah of course e6 hopefully i'm trying
to explain
really because we're playing a 15-minute
game every step of the logic right every
assumption that i'm making
after the game i'll delve a little bit
deeper into why bishop takes c6
check is not something we need to be
afraid of it's not that simple
um ending cleric uh and again what i
encourage you to do if this is going
over your head
try to like first of all interrogate me
that is my freaking job i'm here to
answer your questions
so try to like understand one thing at a
time right
if there's one specific thing you're not
getting ask me to clarify it
uh and and maybe you'll have like one or
two takeaways from the game
so what we need to do here is we need to
figure out a way
to develop these two pieces because
we'll need to castle knight a3 is a very
good move that knight is heading to c4
so we have two pieces and they're
competing for real estate
because if we put our bishop on e7 then
the knight is like whoa
whoa whoa sir sir girl i wanted to come
to eastern but but then we put a knight
to e7
and the bishop is like girl i wanted to
go and get to e7 how do we resolve this
well what we need to do is we need to
bring one piece out
and then leave e7 for another piece and
as you guys are already pointing out the
knight is more mobile in closed
positions
and i'll explain why i can't fiance
fianchettoing weakens a particular
square that's super important
um and so what we do here is we bring
the knight out to d5 or to g6
where it attacks the pawn and then
everybody's happy bishop on e7
you know these pieces get a divorce
we're good all right
equitable settlements all right so do we
go knight d5 or do we go knight g6
very uh let's think tactically
so let's let's do a cost benefit
analysis the benefit of knight d5 is
that it centralizes the knight but there
is a very
interesting cause the cost is it weakens
the d4 pawn
so he can take twice on d4 but then we
have bishop c5
i'll spell this out after the game let's
go knight to d5 it can be kicked away
but then we win the f4 pawn and even if
it is kicked away
we have this nice little retreat square
on c7 where we can tickle the bishop
absolutely the dude why did you spend
all your time in the opening pushing
puns and not developing pieces well
that's not true
girl that's not true i what do you mean
i develop my pieces just as many times
as i push my puns
i mean you have to get your pawns out to
open up squares for your pieces
and so did he like he also pushed his
pawns okay take stakes
now how did the position change as a
result of this trade i want somebody to
tell me
what is now possible as a result
practicing this way of thinking is
indispensable
very important in my opinion for all of
you guys and actually he helps us do
that
how does the position change as a
consequence of this okay our bishop is
now open
he's won a pawn but i saw this right we
can't take because of the pin
and we have two ways of now exploiting
his spin and that's why
f4 is such a damaging move because it
opens the diagonal
yeah so bishop c5 right if we compare
this to queen b6
it's the same thing except now we
develop a piece
and now if everything goes to [ __ ] sorry
if everything goes to goes to crap then
okay worst comes to worst we'll at least
be able to castle we will be able to
evacuate our king from the danger zone
should we fail to win his night which
we're not going to
because guess what ladies and gentlemen
he doesn't have the resources necessary
to protect the knight this is the only
thing he can do queen a4 protects the
knight
how can we now win the night we have
actually several ways of winning the
night but there is one
very important distinction to be made
here
i'm gonna blow your guys mind there is a
better move than queen b6
because let's look let's look with our
tactical eyes let's put on our tactical
glasses here
okay the queen is x-raying the knight
which means if we move our knight then
it's just as effective a move
as queen to b6 but we can't move our
knight just anywhere
because we got to be attentive to
white's threat white's threat is to take
on c6 and win the bishop
so we need to combine the two
observations we need to move our knight
away and protect the c6 pawn at the same
time
and for good measure we're intercepting
the queen which we don't really need
why is queen b6 not as good i will show
that after the game i'm going to keep it
a secret so people stick around
and i'm only going to reveal it for 100
subs like oh my god
so 12 queen b6 explain
so you guys better pay up just kidding
never never never okay night before
we win the night night is a sitting duck
we're up a piece then we're going to
castle
we're going to be grooving
oh my god what did i do what did i do
radcliffed and gifted holy smokes
ratcliff
another 10 gifted
oh my god here's the scary thing this
community is so amazing this might
actually happen midnight
rhino with five oh my lands ladies and
gentlemen
ten gifted from radcliffe five gifted
from midnight rhino you guys are
freaking insane
edo1234 tear winning
holy smokes this is unbelievable i
cannot believe you guys and he resigns
yeah
this is just a piece down and this game
is over after i cancel
that's actually a very instructive game
short but instructive thanks for
thanks for the game gigahertz gyro
priming
thank you
so this move f4
is is reasonable and after d5 e5 is
possible
e takes d5 is considered to be the main
line now listen click carefully anybody
who plays the sicilian guys
you you want to hear this dr butt 3r
think for the prime
so the move queen takes d5 has a
drawback
right it gets the queen out early if
you've seen searching for bobby fischer
you know that that's not always a good
idea what does white have here
why is this not a great idea because
developing your queen early allows your
opponent to develop his pieces
with tempo knight c3 hey white's
developing
his pieces with temple we don't want
that so what we need to do here is we
need to take this pawn
on our own terms how do we prepare to
take this pawn
in a way that doesn't allow our opponent
to develop a tempo
knight f6 now if he goes knight c3 now
we take the pawn and let's compare
process of comparison boom boom
the knights are gone which means he
doesn't have knight c3 which means the
queen is perfectly safe
that is literally the difference between
a good queen and a bad queen the fact
that knight c3 is no longer possible
he can play c4 and a lot of people
associate this with something unpleasant
and i'm so happy people are asking the
question you earned a subject for that
question
this creates a weakness on the d4 square
and we're going to occupy this weakness
by bringing our knight to d4
so here's the rule that you should
remember
the fact that a move poses a threat
does not actually make that move good a
move does not become good
because it threatens a piece
so the move knight c3 in this position
is not good simply because it threatens
the queen
by that token freaking bishop c4 would
be a good
queen that's not a good move right
you're blundering the bishop but makes a
move good
is the fact that it's a developing move
what makes this move even better is that
it develops with tempo right the fact
that it attacks the queen
is an ancillary reason why it's good the
main reason it's good is that it
develops a piece
so if we compare this now to the move c4
this doesn't develop anything
it simply weakens the d4 square
which gives the knight an outpost on t4
and if white goes knight f3 we already
know what the plan is we're gonna
remove that knight from the board and
get the knight to d4
does that make sense right so remember
that
if you are making a move simply because
that move attacks an opponent's piece
reconsider try to find an actual reason
your move is good
and that no sometimes moves like c4 can
be good there are specific reasons but
you guys should be looking at this and
saying girl
rebecca harris what are you talking
about c4
you're defending the pawn what is black
doing you just lose this upon
but there is a reason this is upon
sacrifice it's the gambit what does
black do here to get compensation for
the pawn
and this will segue me into the concept
of compensation
compensation and it doesn't mean a
salary no not b5 right b5
he just goes b3 good thinking guys b5 he
goes b3
and he keeps the pawn chain
the move is e6 okay compensation
are factors that that
make up for the loss of material
right so you're down upon but you have
certain factors in the position
that make up for the loss of material
now what are these factors first of all
white has to take
white is no way to sustain the pawn on
d5 because it has three attackers and
only one defender
mathematically speaking you can't add
two defenders in one move
now after d sorry mouse slip after d
takes c6 bishop takes c6
i want somebody to name three
compensatory factors
that give black full compensation for
the pawn in fact black is better
because black has so much in return for
the pawn it's not even worth the pawn
for white to have this
i want people to number one development
two pieces developed
zero that's one number two
development is good two pieces versus
zero
number two king safety king safety
because white is already pushed upon out
this sticks out like a sore thumb even
if white castles
this diag is gonna be weak ship it
cheese i'm going to give yourself
personally fred ko
dogo thank you for the prime the d4
square
it was weak previously it is incredibly
weak now imagine how freaking sexy that
night will be on d4
girls are going to be inviting this
night to prom i mean there's going to be
a line out the door
to go to prom with this freaking knight
on d4 all right and these three things
taken together
everyone individually might not be such
a big deal but taken together this makes
white's position very nasty
all right that's a giga chad knight
that's right so is black winning here no
but i would say black's position from a
human perspective is more pleasant thank
you buller wins
we're at 19. we need to get to 100. okay
does this make sense at least from a
general perspective
that is why he takes d5 you should play
knight f6 that's a theoretical move guys
actually this is real stuff i'm sharing
with you
okay so gigahertz played e5
uh closing up the center but weakening
the f5 square giving our bishop a very
nice developing square so knight c6
knight f3 bishop f5
and now the move c3 is very sensible for
pairing d4
now at a grandmaster level i would not
have actually played the move d4 i know
that's weird
but this move isn't actually necessary i
would have played another thousand one
satori
keeps the hype rolling with a thousand
bits
i would have played e6 you guys look at
this and say what are you talking about
daniel you're just gonna allow d4
but i want you to do something for me
compare this position
with what we just played the french
right literally this is the same
position with one key difference
with one key difference look at this i'm
literally clicking between the two moves
sorry this one i'm going to click
between the two moves a couple times
this one
or uh this one that's a big freaking
deal
the fact that the bishop is outside the
pawn chain is like a french dream
that's like a french utopia because
there's literally no drawbacks
you've got a french you're attacking the
pawn and the bishop is doing
a freaking work okay so this is a really
good
french for black that's a great position
in the normal french the position is
considered approximately dynamically
equal
so by definition this has just got to be
good
nah it's actually not that bad yogurt
but but why is slightly worse there but
i decided to illustrate the notion of
prophylaxis
the notion of stopping your opponent's
threat so we played d4
bishop b5 is a great move and after e6
thank you maggon for the 100 bits
jiga knight a3 is a great move now the
critical position occurred here knight
d5
and by the way jiggers again not to flex
on you guys
but i'm doing my very best to play the
best moves like i'm not trying to dub
anything down
uh yeah 83 pretty decent i'm not trying
to dump anything down i'm playing my
full strength
now the key mistake was this move
trigger hurts this was the key mistake
you're still doing okay
if you play carefully here the problem
with this move is that it opens up my
bishop
and that's that's just not something you
can allow i would have gone
maybe just not drop the knight back to
e1 you know i know this is not a pretty
move
but at least you keep everything close
to your chest and then you can play the
move d3 and c4
close up the center and white is only
slightly worse
white is only slightly worse after this
well knight takes d4 is truly the
decisive mistake
the move d3 keeps you in the game right
but you have to understand the drawback
of the move f4 yeah he can play well
knight h4 blunders the knight right now
now we just take it with the queen
so what was i going to explain
oh yeah i was going to explain why
knight b4 is better than queen b6
well okay the p back for like not get
100 subs is
you guys are gonna have to tell me i'm
going to confirm or deny
why is queen b6 less accurate in my
opinion than
knight to b4 both moves win both moves
are fine
but this allows a resource it's not
knight c2
because then you just take the knight
you can't take this way because of the
pin queen c2 bishop d4 wins
it's knight c4
what girl thanks for the night we're
chilling
ah we're freaking chilling let's trade
the queens while we're at it yeah i'm
freaking king oh my god knight d6 check
it's a fork with the king of the queen
all right that's the reason we allow the
night passage to
d6 that's a very nasty check
and black can circumvent this well
actually by playing queen to c5 only
move
but why allow a knight to land on this
very nasty outpost
when we can play knight b4 and if knight
c4 here then obviously that that doesn't
do anything we take on d4
and the knight has to detour to e3
so knight ac2 by the way that doesn't
work because we take the knight we
eliminate the defender
and knight takes is not possible because
of the pin queen takes is forced
and bishop takes d4 happens why wouldn't
knight castle
well castling doesn't do the very
important duty of attacking the d4
knight thank you finley may
more so castles allows king h1 and maybe
this is still winning but i didn't want
to play with fire
so um 97 would work malcolm yes 97 is
fine but i wanted the extra assurance
that i'm blocking the queen's defense of
the night i want it to be absolutely
sure also the knight is more
active here than it is on e7 but this is
really splitting hairs
i'm really nitpicking here okay that's
really the main reason all of this
all of this is the main reason
gigahertz thank you so much for the game
any questions from you
because i know you play this line i want
to make sure you're on board with
everything
no i didn't calculate it in advance i
calculated it you know in the moment
well after night before if the king
moves then we just take the knight
if the king moves we take tonight we're
up a full piece for no compensation
white is undeveloped this is lost
so good resignation from gigahertz oh
you got it
now comes the hard part he's gotta play
well okay
so what opening am i going to play you
guys tell me
and i'm not giving you a choice in the
matter i want somebody to tell me what
opening i'm going to play and i've
already determined it
kings it guys kings indian come on
king's indian
kings freaking indian is the opening
of course now i've explained if you go
back through my speed run
at various points i've explained the
king's indian a little bit better
uh but basically what is the fundamental
app good luck man thanks again for your
support what is the fundamental point of
the kings indian what you're doing
and i've explained this several times
it's a hyper modern opening
um i'll tell the story of it once again
later
but basically you're letting white
control the center so f3 is a legitimate
move this is called the sameish
variation
the idea of f3 is to play e4 uh but we
don't need to do anything about that
that's the point of the king's indian
we simply fianchetto our bishop and
white's main move here is e4 now
we don't want to allow e5 how do we not
allow e5 here
like what is the next king's indian move
we play this yeah so d6
and and then we castle and we complete
our development
and now bishop d3 is already a bit of a
mistake this is a very instructive
mistake let me write this down
now the reason bishop d3 is inaccurate
and this goes to the very heart
of the of why the king's indian is such
an annoying opening to deal with
it's very easy for white to neglect his
center so this pawn on d4 look at it
very carefully guys
you see that white has severed the
connection between the queen and the
pawn
how do we target that pawn and this is a
trick question because normally in the
king's indian
what black does is uses his pawns
the problem with c5 or e5 is that
white's just gonna go d5
white's just gonna push the pawn through
knight c6 is the move but you guys look
at this wait wait a second
white still goes d5 okay i'll explain
that after the game
now what can we find another way to
attack this fun
james r with a sub thank you so much we
actually can not e5
not yet not yet move the knight back
boom goes the dynamite we're attacking
the pawn
now why did we do this and finally we
play the movie five
after the game but basically you guys
can understand why i played 97 the
reason i played knight d7
in comparison to e5 d5 here is that this
bishop now comes alive bad bishops
defend good pawns
what square does this bishop x-ray
defend what square does this knight
occupy
central square the bishop supports t4
boom goes the dynamite
94. queen d2
now let's think this knight on d7 it's
blocking the bishop
where can we plant that night 24 hour
parking
these parking spots cost a million
dollars in manhattan
hey move to charlotte knight c5
absolutely look at these knights
look at the pressure they're exerting on
black's fish name that right robert
oh san fran don't don't tell me that
that leads to some traumatic memories
i could write a book about looking for
parking in san francisco okay
now this should be one is a really good
move
there's maybe one is a really good move
he's attacking the knight because he's
threatening with three pieces it's
defended by only two pieces
now here's the thing and this is where
i'm gonna blow your guys's mind
we don't need to defend this knight we
can let him take
and in the time that he is spending
taking that pawn
we can coordinate our forces and prepare
to attack how do we do that
i want people to generate some ideas
beautiful f5 we are already
we're activating the the vacuum cleaner
and he panics bishop h6 i understand why
he does this
but this is a blunder what is this this
is a type
2 undefended piece guys type 2
undefended piece
protected by only one other piece
now we need to combine that observation
and another observation
the moment f3 is played you guys have to
allocate part of your brain
to understanding that this diagonal has
been weakened
which means ultimately a queen could
appear on h4 there's a lot of king's
indian tricks
associated with the queen landing on h4
once we move the knight away from f6
that's another positive byproduct the
queen now has a direct line
to the h4 square boom and we win the
bishop
and the game is over i'm sorry midnight
i'm not treating you any better because
you gifted 50 freaking subs and more
100 subs did i say brain well not your
brain robert
ah i'm sorry midnight
okay
so basically yeah
now the move bishop d3 is it's not a big
mistake but it's an inaccuracy
the main move is bishop e3 now the thing
about the same issues it's one of the
only lines in the king's indian
where white actually castles queen side
that's the main line
that's the main line white actually
castles queen side okay
now bishop d3 is a bit counterproductive
because this pawn becomes weak
so if you go e5 or c5 it allows white to
close down the center which we don't
want to happen now after knight c6
you guys should be looking at this and
saying wait a second can't white go d5
anyway
okay can't why go d5 anyway you would go
knight e5
pressuring the bishop let's say the
bishop drops back to f1
i want you guys to use the method of
comparison compare this position
to this position what differences do you
spot here
what differences do you spot between
this position and
this position this position
this position i feel like it's an eye
test or something
yeah so the knight is developed um it's
it's not if so
on the one hand there's a pawn on e5 on
the one hand there's a pawn on e5
on the other hand there is a knight on
e5
okay so what this basic and there's
another difference the pawn on is on e7
not on e5 so what you can do here is you
can
chip away at the d5 pawn you can play e6
and c6
and you can chip away at this pawn what
happens when you chip away at the spawn
you want the center to get opened
because white's the one who's created
all of these weaknesses by playing f3
does that logic make sense does that
logic make sense so by playing e6 and c6
you're able to rip open the center
and you're able to exploit these
negative externalities that were created
when um when black essentially when
white played f3 which is a very risky
move positionally speaking
let me let's see if i can find any
illustrative games
where i show you this happening let me
see one second guys
let me do a quick chess-based search
here too to put this into perspective i
hope i'm making sense by the way
okay against luke grand master hungaski
against fide master liu
recent game august 2020 internet
tournament i want somebody to tell me
the next two moves that black plays
and i won't tell you unless i get
another 100 subs like oh my god
yeah i'll talk about the inside green
filter in a second e6
you guys great audience e6 c6
he rips open the center boom d5 that
would not have been possible
with white spawn on d5 and he go i mean
just
white resign they look at this king it's
all over the place
a1 queen 18 move game grand master
defeated that's how dangerous this can
be
now admittedly admittedly uh
this is not usual but i want you guys to
really see how effective it can be to
open up the center and the king's indian
he got murked for that reason
this is the move knight c6 97 same
concept if d5 then 95 and actually the
bishop cannot even move
so we're going to take the bishop so the
thing is
uh midnight rhino what specifically
about the anti-grunfeld like what
happens if i play d5
is that what concerns you because d5 is
the grunfeld
and i used to play this with white so i
can give you a couple pieces of advice
but i want to know exactly what you're
asking about
now midnight plays knight g2 and bishop
e3 correctly
now knight d4 and now f5
so by the way there's a very sexy line
you guys want to see a very sexy line
unfortunately it doesn't work now what
you should notice
queen and the rook are unfortable
positions
what sexy move does black have here
using the two knights converting them
into a tactic
your brain should be signaling these
yeah knight b3 so takes takes it's a
fork
what is the problem with this does
anybody see the problem
with this particular idea any more subs
coming well that's not for me to decide
there have been there we go harmonic
diverging to your warning
boom boom and the knight is trapped ah
otherwise we win an exchange
otherwise we win an exchange so instead
we play the move f5 what we're doing is
we're preparing for white to capture
twice on d4 this is probably what
midnight should have done now we take
and we open up as many diagonals as many
files as possible we go queen h4
things get very complicated here
probably white is still better but what
i want to show you guys here is the
concept the concept
of giving up a pawn in order to open up
the position but bishop h6
unfortunately is a blunder due to queen
age queen h4 check
um so the thing is midnight rhino it
sounds like you could benefit from a
line such as the jabal london which
circumvents all of it right you go
knight c3 you basically force d5
and it sounds like you could learn the
london or the jabal london right which
is a little bit less theoretical
from what i'm telling you sound like a
player who your concepts are really good
but you don't like learning a lot of
theories so i could recommend an opening
like that
maybe you look into some chessable
courses
so smile flaws what if fight pushes to
e5 regardless not sure where in which
position what if e5 after d6
okay so if e5 after d6 you take it
you take d1 the king has lost its
castling rights
and okay no problem knight fd7 and i
want you guys to tell me how we
reactivate the bishop because
you might be looking at this and saying
girl this bishop is blunted by white's
pawn chain but we can remedy that
situation
yeah definitely robert that's a great
that's a great call f6
get that bishop out now the thing is
um this idea in the f3 system of
like of the h6 square and queen h4 is so
important
that let's say a white maze makes an
empty move and let's say we're looking
at this and by the way don't take this
with a grain of salt i'm just showing
the concept robert proposed this
this bishop is bad there's a love-hate
relationship with that bishop right it
can get good but let's say we want to
trade it
could somebody devise a tactical method
of trading this bishop
and by the way i call this a positional
combination i'll show you guys a good
example of another positional
combination
in a moment on the topic of this so we
can play bishop h6 anyway
takes queen h4 and we recover the bishop
right
and now we've gotten rid of our worst
piece now
this is not a foreign concept you should
keep this concept in your arsenal of
ideas the concept of
trading pieces in a tactical way
sometimes your opponent has a very good
piece or you have a very bad piece
you want to get rid of it you don't see
a good way to get rid of it think
tactically right you can do positional
things with tactics
it's not one or the other okay
my game against benjamin buck i have the
white pieces
this is an nc grunfeld by the way white
is better
i have a beautiful knight on d5 which is
pressuring that weak pawn on f6
black to play and equalize using the
concept i just outlined
97 97 i've showed this before it's in my
book
blunder the night new queen c5
czechovich
winning the night back active night is
gone black is fine i won the game in the
end i won the end game
but still uh black makes very big
progress toward equalizing so this
concept positional combinations you can
read my article on it online
but uh it's a very legitimate idea
well i would say here uh you could go a6
and stop knight b5 a very good line is
to strike with c5
and and basically go for this structure
with bishop g4 the knight c66
and uh i would investigate like take a
screenshot with your phone
and uh play around with this yeah like
knight c3 is a very unorthodox
positional move that's why it's been
considered bad for most of its existence
but that's why chess has become so
interesting right uh it's like these
recent ideas have been have been
disputed
these ideas that were held very dear
have been disputed and certain lines
have appeared
which a while ago would have been
considered very bad
you